All right, here we go. Uh, a review
that's on time because the brand's not
afraid of it. The 960 XT 16 GB card.
Anyway, yes, there is an 8 GB version.
AMD gets the same treatment as Nvidia.
That should not exist. Uh, anyway,
we're going to compare the $349
uh 960 XT6 GB versus the 5068 GB card uh
which is technically a 299. And I say
technically now because guess what? Uh
we already did the video about the 5060
a few days ago as you guys already saw.
And we showed at the time that there was
the only MSRP model, which is the Prime
that I have right here at 299. Uh
MicroEnter showed that they had some.
They're gone. And not only are they
gone, they're gone for good. Like the
including out of stock items doesn't
show up anymore. Are people People
People can't really be running out and
buying these,
right? For those looking for a high-end
custom gaming experience, look no
further than Falcon Northwest. Falcon
Northwest has been building PCs made for
gamers for over 30 years with a focus on
a true high-end gaming experience.
Custom cases available only through
Falcon Northwest feature
state-of-the-art testing and design to
ensure that every component is
performing at their best through thermal
imaging and rigorous lab testing
designed and overseen by the Falcon
Northwest founder himself. With a
complete lineup of systems ranging from
small to large, every Falcon Northwest
system includes a three-year warranty
policy and a year of two-way overnight
shipping coverage providing the ultimate
peace of mind. To see all that Falcon
Northwest has to offer, follow the
sponsored link in the description below.
All right. Anyway, this isn't about the
5060. It's just what we're kind of
comparing to the 960 XT because these
two are within price parity of each
other. Um, so this is the 960 XT Reaper
model, which is an MSRP model. It's from
Power Color. It is a very small uh very
compact two fan design. It uses a single
8 pin PCI Express. Obviously, we're
comparing it to the MSRP. I guess it was
MSRP, uh, 5060 Prime, uh, which is a
nonTI model, and it's an 8 gigabyte card
because the 5060 only gets the 8 GB
treatment. Um, it's funny. It's It's
like I don't feel like that there should
even be a treatment when it comes to the
Power Color or the 960 XT because it
should only be an 16 GB card, just like
I feel the 5060 should only be a 16 GB
card. It's like I feel every card moving
forward in the future should be a 16 GB
or greater card. But anyway, that's in a
perfect world. Uh let's do this. Let's
go and talk about specs real quick and
then um I have obviously put the 960 XT
through all of our testing. uh this
round versus the 5060. I showed I told
you I didn't do like generational
performance improvements uh when it
comes to looking at things like power
draw and temperatures and all that sort
of stuff because I really saved it for
against the 960 XT cuz I really think
right now it's it's really more relevant
to anyone looking to buy a brand new
entry-level GPU. I say entry level
because there is nothing high-end.
There's nothing even mid-end for these
cards as far as I'm concerned. This is
now the buy-in price point, which is
anywhere between $300 and $350, which is
crazy because we should have $200 to
$250 models that exist at these
performances, these performance figures.
So, that just shows how much the pricing
scale has scooted up where the
performance scale has stayed down
towards the bottom. Anyway, uh moving
on, let's talk about specs right here.
Uh the 960 XT is on Nav'i 44. It's
RDNA4, obviously. Uh it's a uh 4nmter
finfet technology with 29.7 billion
transistors. Um it's a monolithic. It's
funny that they have to state that
because AMD, as you know, does like to
do more um chiplet type designs and
their GPUs are no exception. A lot of
the GPUs that you see from them in the
future are going to be a chiplet type of
design. Architecture- wise, the GB 206
for the 5060. Uh it is also a
5nm/4N finet um architecture. So, they
are very similar in that aspect. 21.9
billion transistors. Um, interestingly
enough though, this is running 8 GB of
GDDR7 whereas the 16 GB and 8 GB models
of the 960 XTs are still on GDDR6. So,
that only strengthens my argument that
there should absolutely not be an 8 GB
model. And because it's running GDDDR6,
which has been around for years now,
there's no reason to have to charge $50
more for it. Unfortunately, this is AMD
still following the suit of the yellow
brick road, or I should say the green
brick road at this point that Nvidia has
paved, telling AMD, "Hey, guess what?
Buyers are suckers. They'll buy
anything. So, let's just you can just
charge more for it." And I think a lot
of people have already expressed their
disappointment that AMD rather than kind
of pushing back against that and saying,
"Let's give the greatest value we can
while giving you the highest technology
and the highest performance we can per
dollar," they're just like, "Hey, we can
get away with charging more cuz look,
Nvidia fanboys are doing it. Why would
AMD fanboys do it? So, unfortunately,
it's not all RGB and rainbows when it
comes to the In fact, there's no RGB on
either of these cards. But anyway, I
digress. It's not all RGB and rainbows
when it comes to AMD because
unfortunately, they've shown that
they're willing to squeeze every penny
out of you guys as well. Anyway, moving
on to the rest of the specs. It is the
960 XT is a 160 watt card whereas the
5060 is a uh 145 watt card. So, they are
very similar when it comes to their
power draw. No surprise there. These are
these are fairly small uh efficient um
designs. Let's go ahead and jump right
into the benchmarks
because I so neither of these cards are
designed for 4K. You should really never
be considering 4K gaming for with these
cards, period. There's absolutely no
reason for that to be the case. Um but
what I will say is that I did 4K testing
on both of these cards. Even though I
didn't show 4K in the 5060, I only
showed a handful of them. I did test 4K
with both of these cards, not as an
indicator of how good they are at 4K
gaming, just putting a very difficult
load on the cards to see uh how far they
sort of separate out when it comes to
their architectures, as well as showing
that that 16 GB frame buffer is
important when it comes to future gaming
games, even when we talk about 1440p.
So, when it comes to Speedway, there's
no surprise that the 5060 beats out the
9060 XT simply because of the fact that
Nvidia is still an entire generation
ahead on their RT core design. Uh, so
it's a 3488 versus a
2925. Now obviously ray tracing is only
part of the story because as soon as you
start looking at rasterization or raster
performance which is just straight up
using those stream processor/cuda
corores uh shaders whatever you want to
call them uh it really paints a
different story because they nearly
perfectly flipped their position by
putting the uh 960 xt on top at 7337
versus a 6425 on our time spy extreme
score. Uh if we go ahead and take a look
at F1 uh 1080p, you can this is where
you start to see some depending on the
title, some pretty big separation
between the two. So the 960 XT gives us
an average 1080p frames per second at
101.7 versus 80.2 for the 5060. So as
you can see, even in 1080p, a big jump
in performance of the of the 960 XT over
the 5060. Going up to 1440, same exact
story. A 73.8 8 average FPS for the 9060
versus a 59.9 or barely a 60 fps for the
5060. Uh if we go ahead and move on now
to Blackmmith Wukong, I want to point
this out. This is a very heavily Nvidia
biased title. We use this title because
we also use the very heavily AMD biased
title of Borderlands. So, it kind of
shows you depending on the games you
want to play and depending on the
developer influenced by the manufacturer
in Nvidia versus AMD and the money
they're willing to throw at the studio
will sometimes determine the type of
performance that you get. Unfortunately,
those politics absolutely do exist when
it comes to gaming. So, the 5060 is
giving us a 65.8 average FPS uh in
Blackmouth versus a
45.1 when it comes to the 960 XT. So,
we're talking 30% less performance uh
for the AMD card versus Nvidia with this
title. Now, in 1440p, same story. The
5060 Prime gets a 44.3 average FPS
versus the 960 XT's 29.9. Uh again, very
heavily Nvidia biased title. If you just
look at our charts, you can see that
almost the whole top of the chart is
Nvidia with a couple of like 9000 series
like 9070 XT actually does pretty well
versus like the 7000 series when it
comes to the old Navi architecture. But
you can see the bottom half of that
chart is heavily AMD. Now, if we go
ahead and flip the script to
Borderlands, which is a very heavy AMD
title, you can see our 960 XT Reaper is
giving us a 140.3 average FPS. It's an
older title. It runs very well even on
lower-end hardware, especially AMD
hardware, but the 5060 Prime is getting
a 115.7. So, a 140 versus a 115. Uh, if
we go and go to 1440p, same exact story.
96.3 average FPS for the 960 XT versus
80.5 for the Prime. Now, if we take a
look at some of the cards that are in
the vicinity though of the 960, even
when it comes to Borderlands, like a
4070 FE uh is the next range up. So, you
move from a 96.3 to a 105.4 for the
4070. Now, obviously, arguably a 4070
cost significantly more than the Reaper
card. So, that just kind of shows
depending on the title sometimes, you
know, there there is that unfortunately
those politics that are involved. Let's
move on to Avatar. Avatar is a title
that um definitely favors high-end
cards. It doesn't really matter if it's
AMD or Nvidia. It's just if you've got a
lower-end card, this title definitely
can bring your GPUs uh to their knees.
In fact, these cards are very very
similar in performance when it comes to
that. So, the 5060 and 1080p Avatar
Frontiers of Pandora is an 80.6 versus a
77.4 for the 960 XT and 1440p, same
story. 54.0 versus a 52.4. Um, in fact,
if you look at the 5% and 1% lows,
they're very similar in these cards,
too. So, it really just shows like the
higherend card, the better when it comes
to Avatar. But, I do like this title cuz
if you look at the 1% and 5% lows, they
scale very, very well um as you move
across the uh the card stack. So,
Cyberpunk 2077, this is a ray trace
medium preset. This is for us testing
things because rasterization as well as
ray tracing uh turned on with the title.
The Reaper edged out a completely
indistinguishable 57.8 versus a 56.6 for
the 5060. To me, that's actually showing
how impressive the RT improvement for
AMD has been since it started RT back
with the 6000 series GPUs and then 7000
series and now obviously we're in the
9000 series. Um, which is showing a huge
gap narrowing when it came to those. In
fact, back in the day, if you compared a
6000 series card to like a 3080 or
whatever, right? If you talk talked
about like a 6T950 XT versus a 3080, uh
it was crazy the gap as soon as you
turned on ray tracing. The ray tracing
performance was just absolutely
terrible. But now they're really close
and in fact indistinguishable when it
comes to the same uh you know tier level
of these cards. So same thing in 1440p.
Uh the Reaper is barely faster than it
at a 35.5 versus a 34.4. And the 5% and
1% lows are very consistent with these
cards. They stay very very similar. So
Cyber Punk's one of those titles that
you want to play, very very difficult to
distinguish the two of them uh from each
other. All right, so talking about
Stalker 2, Heart of Chernobyl or
Chernobyl, very close together as well.
So the 96 XT is at a 65.9 versus a 63.2
uh for the 5060. Now, one thing I kind
of want to point out there is you'll
notice some significantly higher 5% and
1% lows with the 960 XT versus the 5060.
So, I didn't really mention 5% 1% lows
on the other titles cuz they were pretty
much in line. If one had a better
average on the FPS, and they also had
better five and 1% lows. This one's kind
of a different story. So, if you look at
the chart, you'll see 61.1 5% low versus
65.5 for the 5060. And then 97.6 or
excuse me, 57.6 for the 960 versus 48.7
for the 1%. So, a fairly significant
performance and percentage increase on
those lows uh versus the uh average.
Now, if we take a look at 1440p,
uh same sort of thing, but again,
actually very very indistinguishable if
you want to know the truth. We got the
5060 at 47.6 and the 960 at
47.3 and their 1% and 5% lows are
essentially within 1 to 2 FPS of each
other. So, really kind of narrowed when
it came to 1440p. Um, which is kind of
interesting. But it's funny because we
already showed you with the 5060 review
that the 5060 couldn't even launch and
run Stalker 2 at 4K and get anything
more than 2 FPS average. That's simply
because it doesn't have a big enough
frame buffer for that title. and the way
that that title requests and demands uh
frame buffer, it's it's just at that
point it's this title's become fun just
to see will it run when it comes to
lower-end cards. Now, I want to talk
about 4K real quick. As I've already
said, 4K is not a resolution you should
ever consider running with these cards
whatsoever. But in our instance here,
we're using them as a stress test, like
a true stress test, uh and a frame
buffer test, if you will. So, you're
going to notice kind of on average,
depending on the title, the Reaper pulls
way ahead of the 5060. And that is
because of the frame buffer. Even though
it is running memory that is essentially
half the speed of the 5060, it has a
massive amount of RAM available to it,
which is more important than RAM speed
if you need a big frame buffer. So,
looking at F1 2024 4K, the 9060 gets
41.4 for average FPS in 4K versus the
5060's
28.9. So, it's pretty gross actually
when you compare it. If we move over to
Blackmint Wukong 4K, uh again, the title
is very heavily Nvidia favored. Uh so, a
23.6 when it comes to the 5060 versus a
15 flat for the 9060 uh XT. So yeah,
that's one of those things where
sometimes the horsepower just can't
overcome the optimizations on a specific
color, whether it be green or red,
because when we move over to
Borderlands, it's the same sort of
thing. So we got a 50.7 uh for the 960
XT versus a 41.2 for the 5060 Frontiers
uh Avatar Frontiers of Pandora.
Essentially identical numbers, which is
kind of crazy, especially since we do uh
run averages for these cards in
multiples of runs. So it's funny that
they're nearly identical. 27.9 versus
27.9, 5% low is 25.2 versus 25.1, and 1%
low at 24.2 versus 23.9. So, it's
essentially a wash when it comes to
Frontiers of Pandora. Really, it just
favors horsepower. Cyberpunk 2077 4K,
uh, 96 EXT Reaper at 16.1. Again, RT,
very difficult title to run versus a
13.2. And then stalker, we actually got
a 26.1 FPS at 90 for the 960 XT versus
the 5060s 2.2. Again, the 9 the 5060
never even stood a chance. The menu gets
laggy when you enable 4K at the uh epic
settings that we're running right now
with our benchmarks. So, that just shows
how much frame buffer matters. Now,
again, it doesn't matter in this
instance cuz you should not be running
4K for these cards whatsoever. But it's
just interesting that we have finally
found a scenario at which a card and its
frame amount and a title will not
basically run. And you can see all those
zeros on the chart right there. Those
cards that have a zero were so bad we
could not even start the test. You would
push forward on the on the keyboard and
the thing would just not go. You might
get one motion blurred frame and then
you're waiting 10 seconds for it to
render the next frame. It's nuts. So, in
fact, some of them wouldn't even like
run at all. Like, as soon as you got
into the game, it was just like lock up.
So, that's our that that Stalker 4K
Stalker 2 4K is for us basically nothing
more than a dynamometer at its max load
just to see what would happen. All
right, so let's take a look at some
interesting things now like um
temperatures and such. So if we talk
about uh Firmark just doing a max
temperature test on the GPUs, it should
be no surprise that the uh 5060 runs
overall cooler, quite a bit cooler
actually than the 960 XT because it is a
triple fan cooler versus a dual fan
cooler. This has a massive heat sink
versus this. This this essentially has
like double the amount of cooling if you
think about the heat sink density as
well. So, the 5060 caps out in that test
right around 60C. Um, it's kind of
funny. The 9060 XT initially peaks
pretty high up to over 65C, but that's
because of the zero dB mode. Both these
cards have zero dB mode, but it's kind
of slow to react. Now, by the time the
fans come come on and start ramping up,
uh, the temperature starts it has to
come back down. So, it gives you this
weird kind of a bump and then a trend
line that starts to go up where it's
reaching uh about 68 C on average.
That's not terrible, but it's just
obvious that this card is going to be
able to stay cooler because it's
slightly less wattage and it's a bigger
cooler. Now, if we take a look at a
memory test, though, this is where it's
a little disappointing for this exact
card, the Reaper. Now, this is not a 960
XT thing. This is now a power color
thing. the way they've implemented their
cooler onto the board. Junction memory
junction temperature on the 5060 caps
out at pretty much exactly
70°. However, the Reaper does bump into
the '9s. So, for a card that's such low
power, it's a bit disappointing that it
actually is not keeping the memory cool
whatsoever. Because as I look at it, I'm
not going to do a tear down on this card
right now, but I can tell you what's
happened is you got the cold plate on
top of the die and then it just has this
thin copper piece that extends to where
the RAM is. So, you're getting that very
slow transfer of heat through a thin
piece of copper before it gets to the
heat sink. The difference between the
ASUS and the Power Color card is the
heat pipes extend over to where the RAM
is and then comes up. So, that heat can
go up through that copper plate right
into the heat pipe. Whereas on the
Reaper, the heat pipe is only touching
the die. So that's why the temperatures
kind of suck for the memory on the
Reaper. Now that's in Firmark. If we
take a look at uh Cyberpunk, which is an
actual, you know, game to compare the
the
temperatures, you can see once again the
uh GPU for the Reaper, the 960 XT is
reaching 70C and still somewhat climbing
even after 10 minutes. The temperatures
on the 5060 are kind of all over the
place. Like it's kind of funny. And the
reason for that is because it's such a
low wattage card that it's actually
hitting the power limit so so hard that
it does this kind of a a quick reaction
to bring the temp and the power limit
back down. So that's why you see on the
lower-end cards all this zigzaggginess
on Nvidia's side versus uh this card is
not hitting those power limits quite so
hard cuz it's a slightly higher wattage.
But if we go ahead and move on to memory
temp in the game uh in Cyberpunk, same
sort of story. I mean, they're only
hitting about 85C versus 90 versus
Firmark, but that's still really hot for
the memory on a card that's not doing a
whole lot versus like I mean, we were
seeing '90s on the 5090 Founders Edition
card, and that was too hot for a lot of
people. Um, I agree, it's still too hot
in this instance as well, but you can
see that the 5060's memory is hitting
about 62 1/2 C, jumping between 60 and
62 1/2 C. So, it ASUS does a much better
job on the Prime, keeping the memory
cool versus the power color. Uh, last
but not least, let's go ahead and talk
about power. It's kind of interesting
when we look at the power on the 9060
XT, though the 5060. So, you can see the
9060 is bouncing all around between 155
to about 165 watt. Just cuz it's 160
watt card doesn't mean it'll stop right
there perfectly. We measure this at the
cables and the PCI slot. That way we can
see what the true power draw is. It
fluctuates exactly as you would expect
when looking at a game. And this is
Cyberpunk 2077 right here. But you've
got all kinds of curves and stuff
happening with the 5060. This is normal
behavior that we've seen on low-end
cards from Nvidia because when they're
set as low as 145 watts, but they can
still boost up to 2800 MHz. Uh you see
this fluctuation all the time because
the power is going to fluctuate with the
frequency. Speaking of frequency, if we
take a look at frequency,
um, it's very strange to be honest. The
960 XT has a heartbeat. It's like
literally alive. It's the first time
I've ever actually seen what looks like
an actual heartbeat in a frequency. Now,
you got to keep in mind the 96DXT's
design is to boost to over 3,100 MHz if
the like parameters are there to allow
it to boost that high, which usually
would mean not a 100% load. So, as we're
sitting there in Cyberpunk, uh obviously
that load is kind of changing and
because of it, we get very big swings of
all the way down to 2700 MHz and uh all
the way up to over 3,000 MHz for just a
split second. So, that's why we get this
weird kind of a heartbeat. And I'm
assuming we're seeing the interval like
that because as we're sitting there in
the game, things that are happening
around uh are kind of triggering either
the frequencies to go up or down
depending on the power draw. Now, the
5060, as you can see, is a very straight
line right around that 2750 MHz mark
because that is the max boost clock uh
for this card. So, it's the first time
I've seen this kind of a crazy heartbeat
when it comes to the 960 XT. However, if
you look at the uh overall averages and
5% lows and 1% lows on the 96D XT on the
charts, when we looked at the gaming
charts, you can see this weird heartbeat
behavior doesn't actually affect the
overall performance of the game. It's
just a very dynamic clock allowing
itself to adjust quite a bit. I mean,
we're talking like over 400 MHz of swing
versus where it can go versus where it
really lands in a real world scenario.
And remember, 160 uh watts allowed to a
card, you know, available to a card
that's able to go up to like 3130 MHz on
the boost clock. That's kind of crazy to
be honest to try and get those
frequencies at that power uh limit. So
that's why you see this craziness happen
when it comes to these lower-end cards.
Speaking of craziness that's happening,
I'm going to say it again. This should
be a $299 card for 16 GB of GDDR6.
And if you really really wanted to just
drive a nail into that that entry level
buyer, that person that like the 60
series or tier cards on Nvidia, they've
always touted is their biggest sellers
cuz they hit the biggest part of the
market of people looking to spend around
$300 for a graphics card. These guys are
spending over $400 now to buy one today.
there. If you launched a card that is
arguably faster on average across our
titles at the same price, why on earth
would you buy the card that's slower for
the same price? What's hurting it is the
fact that it's $50 more MSRP than the
5060? And what those prices are really
going to be once they hit the market
because again, they're not on shelves
yet. We're filming this before they
launch. It's just it's just sad to to
see them copying a model that Nvidia is
getting destroyed over. So, if AMD wants
to know what their future looks like,
pay attention because you're kind of
skipping down that same
road and you're going to skip right off
the cliff if you're not careful. And I'm
going to say this again, for the love of
God, please make a 9080 XT. You've
already proved the 970 XT is phenomenal.
There MicroEnter told me, like the
employees at Microsenter told me they're
selling four 970 XTs for every one
Nvidia card. Could you imagine if you
could build a card that is able to just
walk all over a 4080 and a 5080, but
it's cheaper? Please do it. Please,
please take the success you're
experiencing and roll back your
statement saying you're not interested
in competing on the high-end market
because I think you're on to something.
All right, time to go. Thanks for
watching, guys. Sound off down below. If
you're shopping at this 300 to $350
price point, which one are you going
with?